hello and welcome to this video playing
soccer man it's not cool man clay say
other kinds that's not a good news we
note that this is a great opening but
I'm not a regular one before player so
this throws me off a little bit I
interesting you tricked me into a g6
system now we are my bishop is not all
that great interesting ok I think I'm
going to play a simple solution now with
this with this ok I have rookie one
potentially and Bishop g5 is also
interesting I don't know if he wants to
go f6f six looks undesirable let's say
okay yeah he had to basically Bishop f6
looked even worse so I'm just going back
here
okay yeah I wonder if c4 as possible
anyway maybe you can take with the night
like a d5 90 x III it's interesting
definitely interesting hmm yeah but I
don't think it works after night x so
I'm preparing this the SC 5 is the most
normal looking move I'm not sure I'm
because with this Bishop out of the play
I might be able to keep the tension
sorry the first words for this day so
that sometimes it's a bit tricky so i
think i'm going to trade on a trade this
Bishop very very likely Bishop g4 looked
a bit annoying yeah now I'm ready for um
bishop age 6 he might have Knight f6
here okay didn't do it I thought that
this was an interesting move 494 okay
okay cannot go night you for now so what
i can do is i can try to get best
possible control of 85 we should be five
looks very logical in that regard the
bishop didn't do much anyway and i think
i'm just threatening to maybe to take on
c6 and then go 95 that is at least
strategically okay it doesn't think it's
a threat even encourages me to take
which is rather surprising I need to
make some salt wicker moves took a bit
too long at the beginning okay so nitey
fault i'm going to prevent night h5 i
can just go jeet form and kick him kick
him back this one okay we night a force
on the agenda anyway so the knight on c3
was misplaced and going YF for d3 is a
very logical approach okay night f4
maybe we should be five Abby should be
fun right doesn't really work I can take
on e6 yeah here if i get to trade the
dark squared bishop sand play with the
night only five against them against
that that light squared Bishop that then
then this position is just winning so
we'll see
if he is able to prevent that oh I mean
that's also helping me but okay under
the position blacks position is
objectively am completely lost so it's
probably probably doesn't really make a
whole lot of difference what he is doing
okay so i think i need 93 but should be
five that is the thing that would help I
wonder if I go Quincy 3 and 93 might
have quinta c4 yes but if all the time
in the world here to get this properly
prepared so here and this is actually it
is not a completely clear situation if
he gets the Queen to see form really not
chief okay I'm going and I'm going with
this now it is bad if white but I
thought I had more simply yeah Quincy
for now answer it's not playing it okay
it's never going to play move i expect
probably one of those games okay if he
takes i cannot take with the night that
that's really bit of a shame time
morning now i can I wonder if Quincy for
is still an idea to to somehow activate
William charges following entirely
different ideas obviously so I've got
all the entries squares covered just
have to go to e2 now nh4 is also strong
but ok the ending is just very simple so
we cannot trade and now
and maybe for each for
it's not all that all that easy check
that's the toss that was very very
stupid and was extremely stupid I could
have just taken c 6 i'm not quite sure
if this is still winning really not
check check check check check mate with
0.2 very important who I didn't didn't
convert this position where I am
absolutely not absolutely not there
should be a very simple win but I
couldn't really I didn't didn't play it
well yeah I'm okay with that this should
be it should be fine really ok h four
wins according to the computer which is
not very surprising but ok this also
should win but i have to play this age
for business Yung I wasn't completely
sure to be honest what I didn't seem
that he cannot enter anyway I have got
every square covered I was thinking
they're still on
some possibility for him to enter but it
just isn't the case I'm just trying at
threatening to take and go clean age one
age six and that that's definitely over
and so that would have been moving
better I mean okay the way it was played
Chad Kingda to was just a total totally
brain-dead move I can just take here and
win easily and yeah it's this stuff it
is still probably winning and the engine
confirms that it still wins but of
course that was blundered I shouldn't
have allowed that um yeah that was a
strange game because he simply didn't do
anything against being strategically a
crushed with very simple means actually
so here like a move like a six I don't
know I mean I take anyway but this
position is already very bored in line I
think for like the engine gives y plus 1
which is conservative I think he has so
many weeks week squares pieces it is
probably losing if Y place place really
perfectly okay I'm happy to go down and
starting starting here by the way I
think that you have the computer
confirms i was thinking that g4 is
probably very strong just playing for an
attack but well an ending is an
automatic win almost so this is what i
try to to go for and which worked out in
a way just in a very shaky form if i
would have seen that age for IDM it
would have been much much cleaner and
overlooking check yeah i only saw it now
official page 3 what sign is stupid but
okay Chester a complete win but in eight
seconds so I'm happy that I manage that
would have been a bit frustrating to
lose a game that was such an inside of
the fam you will extremely quick after
same check checkmate yeah we're with
absolutely no time left okay guys thanks
for watching